.
AND YOU DID IT SO WELL,
THANK YOU.
NOTING THAT AS THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS PICK UP DEMOCRATS ARE
CALLING FOR MORE POLICE FUNDING
AND ATTEMPTING TO CO-OP
TRADITIONALLY REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINTS ON CRIME.
IF YOU HAD ANY RESERVATIONS IN
CALCULATING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT THAT PASSAGE PUT TO REST
BECAUSE FOR TWO YEARS POST
GEORGE FLOYD THEY LET THE BODIES
PILED UP ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND
ONLY WHEN IT BECAME POLITICALLY
CORRECT TO THE CALL FOR MORE
POLICE.
JOHNNY SNELL'S ARKANSAS
SENATOR MEMBER OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THIS SHOULD BE A WARNING ANY
VOTER WHO THINKS THE DEMOCRATS
TRULY CARE ABOUT CRIME WHEN IN
THIS DR CASE THEY STILL CAN'T
SAY ANYTHING CLEAR ABOUT THIS
GUY'S MOTIVE WHEN HE TELLS US
WHAT HIS MOTIVES ARE ONLINE.
I COULDN'T BE MORE OBVIOUS WITH
THE GUY WAS TRYING TO DO.
>> I KNOW IT'S AN AMAZING CHANGE
OF HEART DO NOT TO BE TOUGH ON
CRIME.
I MISS WHEN IF THEM TOMORROW TO
SEE THEM PROTECT UNBORN BABIES
IN YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT
AS WELL.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS IS
HAPPENING BUT HERE'S WHAT WE
SHOULD ALL KEEP IN MINE IS NOT
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
A VICIOUS CAMPAIGN SPIN FROM
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT AMERICANS PREPARE TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE AT THE BALLOT
BOX THE FACT WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
INCREASE IN MURDER RATE ON
HISTORY.
THAT SO MANY CITIES NOW PARENTS
OR YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT LAYING
THEIR KIDS GO PLAY IN PARKS.
WHETHER THEIR KIDS CAN WALK HOME
SAFELY FROM SCHOOL OR FROM A
BALL GAME.
AND IT'S GETTING DARK.
THAT'S A DIRECT RESULT OF
DEMOCRATIC POLICIES AND STATE
FUNDING POLICE OR BILL SYSTEMS.
CUTTING PENANCES FOR
DRUG DEALERS JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO THE CHEAPEST OF STAFF GAVE A
SPEECH CELEBRATING THAT THEY
JUST LET OUT MORE FELONS FROM
FEDERAL PRISON THAN ANY
ADMINISTRATION HISTORY.
DESPITE WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE AND
ALWAYS HAVE BEEN SOFT ON CRIME
AND THAT IS ENDANGERING
AMERICANS.
>> Laura: THEY CLAIM THAT
REPUBLICANS WANT TO CRIMINALIZE
POVERTY.
THAT'S THE LINE FROM THE
PROGRESSIVE IN NEW YORK AND
BALTIMORE OAKLAND.
ST. LOUIS.
THEY ARE THE CALLOUS ONES.
WHEN IN FACT THE CALLOUSNESS OF
THE DANGER COMES FROM THIS
REVOLVING DOOR OF CRIMINALITY.
AND THAT SUSPECT IN NEW YORK HIS
RAP SHEET WAS QUITE LONG.
HE HAD TIES TO NEW JERSEY AND
PENNSYLVANIA.
IN WISCONSIN AND OHIO.
THE DETECTIVE SAID HE HAS NINE
PRIOR ARRESTS IN NEW YORK.
FOR A POLICIES GIVEN WITH SOME
REFORMS THAT THEY ARE COMING.
THE STATS TELL THE STORY DO THEY
NOT?
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO
CRIMINALIZE POVERTY AS THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T CRIMINALIZE
ANYTHING.
IN PLACES LIKE PHILADELPHIA TO
REFUSE TO ENTIRE CATEGORIES OF
CRIMES IN MANY CASES SERIOUS AND
EVEN FINALLY CRIMES.
THOSE ARE THE PROSECUTORS THEY
ARE CONTRIBUTED TO THE RISE OF
INCREASES IN THEIR CITY.
IT'S NOT REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE
BEEN PROCESSING ELIMINATE CASH
BAIL AND PLACES LIKE NEW YORK
WHICH THEY DID THE RESULT OF
THAT REVOLVING DOOR OF SERIOUS
CRIMINALS BEING ARRESTED AND
IMMEDIATELY GETTING RELEASED AND
GETTING FINED AGAIN.
THIS IS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STANDS FOR.
MEMBER KAMALA HARRIS WAS BAILING
WRITERS AND ARSONIST OUT OF
PRISON IN MINNESOTA TWO YEARS
AGO ENCOURAGING HER SUPPORTERS
TO GIVE MONEY TO BUILD FUNDS IN
MINNESOT